thank you to Harry's and expressvpn for
sponsoring more on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
it is I Andrew and we are about to take
a trip when special effects were a lot
less complicated back to the year of
1982 it is of course the film I'm
talking about Tron and I'm of course
joined by my brother from another mother
janio you do howy you doing my man I'm
doing all right I'm ready to tackle this
classic sci-fi film me too I'm excited I
am a little bit sad there is no da punk
in this soundtrack I don't think they
were a thing back then but uh you know
we'll make do with this one but let us
know in the comments section what do you
think of this film I'd love to hear your
thoughts and uh you know do all the
YouTube things hit the Subscribe button
Bell icon all notifications and leave a
like so you can let us know that you are
enjoying the content that we are
bringing you and all the great special
effects that that Tron has brought us
over the years also we want to give a
special shout out to prepper they do
such a wonderful job of editing down
these videos especially from me where I
give all these crazy references to
everything so thank you so much prepper
also full length Reaction watch along
where you sync up with your own copy
it's where you do a patreon it's where
we call you super sexy it's where you
can enjoy the whole film with Johan and
myself you get to have the full
experience of the Tron you get to see
all the cool special effects with us you
enjoy it and also John Greg they have so
many exclusive other things on there
from TV shows movies so many highlights
you get to hear all the fun little
references of everything that I get to
do from every movie and TV show that I
come on do it it's such an amazing time
seriously you will not regret it and
John anything else before we get going
for our tonon nope just just I'm ready
for Jeff Bridges all right let's get it
going
I like it that's so80s
yes yeah perfect 80s computer text yes
God I wish we grew up in that
area
dang we shall waste no time let's get
right to the titles yeah got to get our
iconography
[Music]
established kind like a almost a Pac-Man
Vibe here yeah Pac-Man motherboard
cityscape
flynns oh they have one at California
Adventure oh really damn that's awesome
all right give me room here we
go oh man we are just getting right to
it whoa
[Music]
nice David Warner hey rest in peace rest
in peace yeah I was going to
say for 1982 this is spectacular
sure like state of the art back
whoa he die in the game you died for
real this is how the Matrix was
born fascinating animation yeah curious
what the budget was back then for this
you're getting brutal sir brutal and
needlessly
brutal thank you master control we kidna
some military programs I can arrange
more illegal matches sure I'd love to go
up against one of those guys make a nice
break from those accounting cream puffs
you keep sending
me at least make it a challenge for me I
hear his voice I just hear Ral Ghoul
from Batman in the Animated Series sure
I work at a savings and loan I can't
play these video games sure you can't
pal you look like an Asal athlete if I
ever saw
what hey look you guys are going to make
my user Mr Henderson very angry he's a
full branch manager another religious
nut this is a fascinating Society really
love this animation you believe in the
users yeah sure if I don't have a user
then who wrote me but does the user
believe in you master control program's
been snapping up all us programs if he
thinks you're useful takes over all your
functions so he gets bigger and if he
can't use you sends you down here to the
game grid to get the bits blasted out of
you yeah it's like agent Smith or
something what's your name
Chrome Ram Chrome and RAM hey uh what's
been going on the other sectors you know
I've been stuck here for 200
microcycles jeez I think you can't even
travel around your own micro circuits
without permission from master control
program I mean sending me down here to
play games who does he calculate he is
it's a fascist game of society hey let's
go sexy young Jeff okay clue tonight we
check everything in the right hand
column clue program clue yes sir clue we
don't have much time left to find that
file this is top priority yes sir I know
sir this isn't just correcting my bank
statement or phone bill problem again
this is a must I understand sir it's
just called clue Skynet sure now you're
the best program that's ever been
written you're dogged and Relentless
remember let me add him that's the
spirit let me add him I'll try to cover
you from this end go dogged and
Relentless good ad wait is that CH
bridges too did he make his avatar look
like
himself it's hard to tell I think so
when they have people on screen ah okay
that answers that
yeah it almost looks like a silent movie
at times yeah that's that's a good way
to describe it yes now Flynn is staying
to look over in here cuz there's no
background music
too and man half the sound effects are
the background music
yeah come on you scuzzy data be in
there oh this is so old school I love it
this is how we communicate with AI now
we've got
[Music]
company
fascinating I recognize
[Music]
her there's some there's some score
music
yes there's too many of them sure blast
all the Arches great kid don't get
cocki jeez what what did they do is each
one a portal do they like pinch
you
uhoh come on man boss
[Music]
battle
[Laughter]
a
uhoh uh-oh get out of here get out of
there
[Music]
clue the
Sentinels I really feel like I'm the
wichowski like saw this and took a
little inspiration for sure definitely
some shwn in The Matrix got a pirate
program here says his name's clue came
into the system with a stolen password
and we got him trying to raid a high
Clarance memory no I must have gotten in
there by mistake I was
simp
whoa throw him in the prick who's your
user forget it Mr high and mighty Master
Control forget about it you are making
me
talk oh we got that single teardrop
going
oh
[Music]
oh this is fascinating this must have
taken so long yeah back in 1982 it must
have been like hand manipulating so many
of these frames yeah remember when you
got me to have a single tier drop when
you were the Winter Soldier that's right
man that was true acting you're a
thesbian Andrew n you you got it out of
me my
man look at this gamer you know the
first movie I ever saw him in Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles 2o Secret of the O
Yep looks like Tron but it's the real
world good evening Mr Dillinger thank
you Peter you can go now yes
sir have an office
greeter they had high tech tabletops as
far back as the80s this is just like the
ultimate desirable future yes every
movie about the future has
one no problem Master C sure when people
saw this they were like oh my God it's
the future what's up it's your friend
the boy detective he's nosing around
again Flint oh he still looking for that
old file can't you just appropriate it I
have I put it in my memory which she
hasn't
located I spotted him this time and kept
him out but he's getting trickier all
the time AI is learning shut down all
access until we find that Flynn just to
be safe there's a
68.7% chance you're right cute cute I
would have loved if they had James earol
Jones for that voice I mean who wouldn't
yeah oh happy 93rd birthday today by the
way James earol Jones oh dang I guess
you guys will know when we're shooting
this now they can figure it
out oh what are you doing here
guy you guess see machines run off the
honor System Alan you think I can have
some of your god look how endless this
office is yeah oh good that's a lot of
cubicles it's not that different from
the inside of Tron it's just a maze
corporate rat race it's like I'm on to
you you're the mold to
Flynn
damn he just turned to the window so he
could turn back around he's got to have
his bad guy pose John Tron yes for the
rest of this video I will be Tron you
are Tron and you will be and clue group
seven Personnel just briefly security
you're you're improvising skills so good
well I hope you don't think it's me I
don't even balance my checkbook on
downtime I have an abacus at home for
that oh high tech what's the project
you're working on well it's called Tron
it's a security program itself actually
monitors all contacts between our system
and other systems finds anything going
on that's not scheduled it shuts it down
oh part of the master control program no
it'll run independently of course it
must well we should have you running
again in a couple of days I hope you
hope
thanks very productive me Dillinger
seems like such a genuine Guy Mr
Dillinger I'm so very disappointed in
you oh no I can't afford to have an
independent programmer monitoring do you
realize how many outside systems I've
gone into how many programs I've
appropriated got to be staggering right
now oh perfect timing you going to knock
on the elevator open up oh D yes I want
a laser Bay button in my elevator never
been to a laser
[Applause]
Bay you know it is important to get your
vitamin C while you're gaming all day
so if you're not going to have it at
halftime the soccer game you got to do
it while you're gaming all
day
oh is that Cindy Morgan is it rest in
peace well here goes nothing yeah
December 30th she passed oh no she was
in the classic catty Shack well what I
meant was actually what we proposed to
do is to change something into nothing
and back again then he might just as
well have said here go something here
comes nothing right thank you man that
that's me at the
party it's true John is very good at
explaining things it's not technically
turn a
phrase let's see if we got the green
light give me the green
lights oh
yeah let's
go
wow who invented that Oppenheimer
sure
perfect damn that that that was fast
beautiful hi Alan Alan I I I understood
that reference a laser dismantles the
molecular structure of the object that
guy's voice sounds so damn familiar
plays out the model like the molecules
fall back into place and SW great can it
send me to
Hawaii but you got to purchase your
program 30 days in advance dude you'll
be 3D printing dinner in no time I had
TR almost ready when Dillinger cut
everyone with group seven access out of
the system oh what do you know man that
was a suspicious look got to expect some
static after all computers are just
machines they can't think oh oh you know
it computers and the programs will start
thinking and the people will stop that's
the dream I was all set did he say why
something about Tamp yeah he's on to you
you know Flynn has been thinking about
breaking into the system ever since
Dylan your candas oh Flynn used to work
here okay Flynn had access to you too oh
okay bro reing get jealous I want to go
to Flynn's place what for to warn him
what you like him better than me don't
be insecure man I don't know what you
ever saw on that guy any I love him for
his brains yeah I just figured out why
it's called Flyn yeah cuz he's an
entrepreneur and he loves games Bo I
haven't been here in a long time I would
love to own arcade it'd be awesome yeah
man you could from the ELC aside from
the electric bill and the the cost of
rent that'd be awesome let's get some
solar panels bro get that right
off home of space paranoids interesting
man I used to love going to the arcade
growing up yeah barcades are still fun
arcades and
barcades where is he I don't know
somewhere at least pretend like you want
to be here yeah I would love if he's on
like DDR with like a crowd of kids
around him using both pads showing off
all right let's see what product
placement we can find John or
Tron hey there we
go see he's that
[Music]
good God remember sexy young Jeff
Bridges can't compare video games of the
80s
nope it's funny is this would actually
be kind of fun if they ported it to like
a VR if you had a Tron game that was
actually like in VR oh yeah that'd be
awesome it's all in the hips that's
right that's right I heard I got a shout
you out I heard I heard hey good to see
you guys classes up the Jo like a
cleancut young couple yeah we got to
talk we can't even yourself thinking
here come on damn man working up with
sweat oh see that camera shake at the
end
there right up damn he worked up a sweat
playing that game yeah so if anybody
says video games aren't a sport you just
show them to that scene exactly have you
been sneaking into the encom
system right to business I have been
doing a little hacking here as a matter
of fact you did break in you son of a
[__] Flynn are you embezzling bezeling
is such an ugly word Mr Bradley oh
actually I'm trying to get some solid
evidence together yes I don't get it
going to take the machine to court
Sherman set the way back machine for 3
years ago Kevin Flynn one of income's
brightest young software Engineers he's
talking about himself his own private
memory file and begins writing a program
for a video game Ed called space
paranoid paranoids made Blaster B Squad
a whole slew I was this close to
starting my own little Enterprise yeah
but enter another software engineer not
so young not so bright but very very
sneaky Ed Dillinger fraking Dillinger so
when night our boy fnny goes to his
terminal tries to read up his file I get
nothing on there he a big blank he
doesn't exist he's a ghost this is nice
Exposition for the audience I still
don't understand why you want to break
into the system because man somewhere in
one of these
memories is the evidence oh my god this
is my password dillingers instructions
do to birt the DAT of the whole shop no
dillingers cut off everybody with group
seven access wait wait
what well now there is nothing to stop
him now it's just Dillinger and the mCP
running things from onhe not if my Tron
program was oh he said the name let's go
let's go you know if your file was in
there wait a minute if we can get in
there I can forge us a group six
access let's get Clue on it
oh well you know how frustrating it is
when you're working on a piece of
research well do I sympathize but I have
data coming from the master control
program telling me there's something
screwy going on around yeah I can't sit
here and worry about every little user
request that comes in user requests are
what computers are for doing our
business is what computers afford ooh
the
ethics uhoh very quick cutscenes do you
even have control of the mCP
you know what's funny is this actually
kind of you can see where free guy got a
lot of ideas from I have not seen free
guy it's on the list well he he's Tao
itti ah David Warner is Tao iated pieces
of equipment in existence oh I know all
I think this guy was in Sister Act 2 if
I'm I'm not mistaken that's Lauren Hill
yes it's Lauren Hill you know you can
remove men like Alan me from the system
but we help create it and our spirit
remains in every program we design for
this computer ghosts in the machine I've
got better things to do that have
religious discussion as I say s direct
to I think it's father Maurice if I'm
remembering correct through Jesus Christ
Our Lord
amen let us pray I don't think I'm
cleared for this well I'm certainly not
you want to move aside give the kid a
little room come on let's do some 80s
hacking let's hack our way in do some
John Connor moves make these myself you
want
one easy
money what a
door
damn damn that is that is a thick
boy I would close that door my fault I
programmed you to want too much I was
planning to hit the Pentagon who what
Pentagon it shouldn't be any harder than
any other big low go now wait a minute I
wrote you I've gotten
2,415 smart that's very specific the
same thing I want with the krlin and
board Corporation oh damn the
information I can access I can run
things 900 to 1200 times better than any
human wow you wouldn't want me to dig up
Flynn's file and read it up on a
VD wow I shall threaten you it's like
it's like free guy and
Skynet I don't know the reference of the
first first one but the second I do I'm
going to put him at my terminal I'm
going to meet you in your office
upstairs don't fall asleep if and when I
activate your TR programming have a few
minutes to use it before Dinger catches
a break in security all right he going
to fall asleep it's where Freddy Krueger
gets you the
time damn who whose server room did they
borrow for
this I think they went to the local
laundry mat and they turned it into this
yeah the home appliance section of your
local hardware
store Gort clu barata
Nicko The Day the Earth Stood Still and
by extension Evil Dead ah okay that's
why we got Jenny Army of Darkness I
guess but anyway reference as I got to
see that too keep those programmers out
of the system and get me that Chinese
language file I asked for you can't
access a Chinese Lang file with your
infinite
power interesting to see him feeling so
like defensive and helpless now yeah his
creation is running a muck come on I'm
I'm scared in the dark all this
technology scares me come
on damn and yet you chose to spend your
life surrounded by it back in the laser
Bay it's an excellent sneaking Montage
scene not making a a lot of noise like
ninjas like this this literally is
halfway between a scene and a
montage oh man man says there's no
problems only solu that old printer
remember this laser is my life's work
don't spill anything don't spill any
laser
juice
clue H they cut away oh another okay now
we know the
password you shouldn't have come back
for hey it's the big master control
program everybody's been talking about
remember the time we used to spend
playing chest
together oh let's go what do you got I'm
afraid
stop you realize I can't allow this now
how are you going to run the universe if
you can't even answer a few
unsolvable sure go against you and see
what you're made of you know you don't
look at oh he's put him into the game oh
no I'm going to have to put you on the
game
yeah
damn we are doing
[Music]
this jeez damn I'm loving that that
effect and it is like like a printer
like a reverse printer almost going line
by
line fun I know it came out seven years
later but it reminded of where Honey I
Shrunk the Kids Cut
the oh my god let's go through the
digital Doctor Who
Rift you unlock this door with the
motherboard of imagination a dimension
of pixels chips and of monitors sign
post up ahead the Tron
[Applause]
zone I'm curious if someone has edited a
version where there is Da punk in this
they must absolutely have
done wow
wow oh this must have been such a trip
in 82 seeing all this yeah oh my God
what I wouldn't have given to see this
in a theater like at the time oh yeah I
would have been just blown
away that's want to see Flyn meat clue
yeah and then make
out Dre my mind
oh man this isn't happening it only
thinks it's
happening it's a matter of perspective
careful entry Port
program I said move whoa look if this is
about those parking tickets I can
explain everything okay yes of course it
is yes I would love if that's actually
what it was parking enforcement always
gets physically violent over those kinds
of things I've got a little challenge
for you sock what whoa it's a tough case
but I want him treated in the usual
manner Zordon let himself go is this
Zordon on the dark side yeah I've been
hoping you'd send me somebody with a
little bit of guts see he needed a
challenge is not any kind of program s
he's a user a user oh you look nervous
it's just users wrote us a user even
wrote you yeah no one user wrote me I'm
worth millions of their man years jeez
you rather take your chances with me
want me to slow down your power cycles
for you
oh oh get this clown trained I want him
in the games until he dies play
knowledge sure hey will you call him
programs program
[Music]
wow it's like an expressionist movie
really think the users are still there
they better be all right so obvious D
blue represents users who are you guys
no you want to watch those Force steals
you couldn't have said that before where
am I you're uh that guy looks familiar
guest of the master control program they
going to make you play video game you're
saying this isn't the parking
enforcement agency I play video games
better than
anybody did that guy play Billy the Kid
and Bill and Ted oh sure looks like that
could be him kind of does look like him
that that movie was years later than
this but that could be him good ey now I
can't unse it yeah
bogus this is so many things this is
like a weird like hisory Roman Empire or
something but in a computer they got
these like Centurion guys Gladiator
games sar's carrier is approaching you
will explain the training
procedures yeah the ship from Star Wars
but digital is
approaching the master control program
has chosen you serve your system on the
game continue to profess a belief in the
user he's like that's Dillinger the
standard substandard training which will
result in your eventual elimination jeez
the standard substandard
training this superstitious and
hysterical belief join the warrior they
couldn't mic this guy up
you will each receive an identity disc
everything you do oh will be imprinted
on this disc live or die make your
choice or fail to follow commands you
will be subject to immediate der
resolution I'm really surprised they
couldn't get him a mic for that like
half these dudes are like what you say
mic in the digital world yeah in
cyberspace no one can hear you gream or
give an address that's funny that is
funny who's that guy that's he fights
for the
users Tron I am
Spartacus
W damn so cool
oh yeah damn hey Ram what were you you
know before I was an Actuarial program
for big insurance company how about
yourself I don't remember too much
name's Flynn sure a little
disorientation that's normal in
transport it'll come back sounds good Mr
the
Flynn that's funny let him fight one of
his own kind
oh he looks so happy to be here looks so
amused are you not
entertained
yeah Gala
Gladiator
one of those
Scoops going to play like oh they going
to play
tennis this is like futuristic racket
ball
cat okay whoa starting to get this game
so you get the max points if you hit the
center
ouch I love the sound design yeah okay
here's an easy
[Music]
one oh come on wa so it gets rid okay I
see now okay this is neat yeah yeah whoa
what a
shot finish the game finish him
no you'll regret this yeah yes there's
definitely a lot of inspiration into
other films that came after this oh yeah
oh my God this it's you know obviously
the technology isn't where it could be
to realize a vision like this but yeah
this is like cutting so many edges and
breaking so much ground oh for sure I
want in the games until he dies playing
jeez how much more do I owe on these
parking tickets yes I would love to play
off my parking tickets you one Alan
where did you hear that name yeah Alan
well that's your name isn't it I heard
it from a velociraptor why did you say
that name how did you know I'm a program
from a user that knows Allan he was
disoriented in transport trunk yeah but
I'm remembering all kinds of stuff like
my user wants me to go after the mCP my
user wants that
too did we just become best friends
yep and to do all these digital
sequences as if there was a camera I
can't even imagine back then how long
this must have taken to
do
yes oh here we go we're doing it we're
doing
itue bikes guys into yeah andit up take
them
[Music]
one cool oh the sound is H yeah got
every time they do that and they take
those sharp turns like my heart skips a
beat oh feel like we're on Endor
[Music]
yeah
oo oh my God it watch
[Music]
it
no okay okay who's still left in the
[Music]
game oh get him into the maze yes lose
him oh my
God is it come on oh let's go let's
go into the void
oh
fre to goal two and one I'm getting out
of here right now and you guys are
invited got it let's go free the
[Music]
people
oh uhoh yeah y'all going to get picked
[Music]
off is that Billy the Kid gone yeah I
think I think we lost Ram this is an
illegal exit must return thank you for
the notification is an illegal exit you
must return to the GD what are they in
the sewers of Tron or of uh the program
of space paranoids whatever we should
call this
[Music]
place get them shrink through that
doorway it's a Pac-Man yay literally
Pac-Man we called that earlier yeah it's
like this design looks familiar I wonder
if Pac-Man is their God targets leaving
protected
field
interesting game
arena I'm trying to process what the
logic is here like it cuz it feels like
they just like broke out of an actual
Arena into like the surrounding City
sewers Etc but I'm also like is this
functioning like some kind of hidden
area of the map within the program
someone had to design this
space
yeah I was worried about
that I love the prism effect for the
[Music]
Sparks this score music is so
fascinating
whoa okay thank goodness Billy's still
around on the other side of the screen
it all looks so easy sure it's just
joysticks and button pushes when do we
pay our visit to the old uh master
control huh just three of us well you
know anybody who's got an army for rent
that's fine but my user told me to go
take that sucker out I'm never getting
out of here you are the user we can't
get to the mCP without the help of my
user I have to get to that input output
Tower yeah my user is with your woman
yeah what's
that that is just what I need right now
what what what is it
whoa damn God these effects bathe in the
Living
Waters
what it's the Fountain of Eternal youth
yes oh you forget how good the power
feels till you get to a Pure Source ah I
see okay so it's like just pure energy
represented as water thank go I can feel
it Allan one let's move on
go
Allan out in the real world not falling
asleep okay you're an addict man the
lighting effect when they drink it so
cool
yeah that's that Panera Bread lemonade
in there he got the extra caffeine
[Music]
boost range n no
no
no Pursuit Force reporting two escape
units durz no damn Say It Ain't
So Good play dead Ram oh no no come on
we got to get out of here no don't be
dead dude
going to need more of that water now I
know what what's making that chirping
sound than won't find us
here it's
minox I thought this was supposed to be
[Music]
easy well you should have set the game
to beginner mode you always start on
beginner mode and then work your way up
once you get the hang of
it
you got the Rhythm did you activate yeah
you can't just be falling asleep on
stuff half of everything in here could
be buttons you see this you shouldn't be
able to do
that you're powering the system powering
the
[Music]
sector
wa cool so cool make a mega sword make a
[Music]
Gundam hey hey we got our
own little janky leg work in
progress oh little steering wheel
yeah yeah yes of course it
is sweet
hey you okay you don't look so good
we'll get you fixed up hang on come here
just pay attention yeah are you a user
a no buddy when good touch with with the
blinking oh yeah yeah yeah it's almost
game
over
Ram
no
ug you will live on in our Random Access
Memories Justice for
[Music]
Ram I thought that was Matthew mccon for
a sec all right all right all right just
doesn't age like the rest of us we've
got to go inside the machine all them
circuits and wires got to twist them
around fairy
dust this was so much EAS easier in the
real
world yeah he's going to have so many
tickets on this
machine I got to get to that IO Tower
yes you do attention all units lock onto
Matrix code wow what's the progress on
the simulation 3056 99 are correct
limited four and eight are missing is
that
s where's her spectacles I can't tell if
that's Cy Morgan I guess you wouldn't
need them in the game hey 30 okay it is
Cindy Morgan limited four and eight are
missing oh I
think I love
you hey reunited and it feels so good
they haven't built a circuit that could
hold you yeah where can we go this way
quickly yes let's go a lot of pregnant
pauses in this movie I
appreciate oh my goodness he's got a
merchandisable friend now I need one
where's my toy want a Funko Pop
[Music]
who
steady stay on
target oh knocked down one of the tanks
yeah took me a second to realize that
pull it together
man
nice
okay what's this do how about this one
what does this Buton
[Music]
do that's the Dune sector right there
that was like the Benny jesset those
hooded
figures I'm glad just want to know where
paot traes
is oh
oh it's okay Tron is Polish
poies offline offline I'm
fine oh this town is full of live ones
sure
is whoa
damn
oh shall blend in with my enemy cover
yourself in zombie guts
so what does that mean exactly did you
just absorb his like clearance and
essence or are you like one of those
guys now he's join the Dark Side John
more
guards they're just chilling over there
aren't they supposed to be on rotation
these are computer guards they should
just be on guard he had one chop to do
yeah you had one job that your
programming dictates you
do
and the shading too as they look around
the corner there fascinating I'll go
first
W Let
Go I mean he just got beamed right there
what do you want I've come to
communicate with my user difficult
proposition difficult proposition oh
that's the uh the guy said from SRA too
sure the laser Bay they hate this Tower
they'd close it down if they did but
they like my phallic hat too much to
deal with the other world once in a
while
dant we could make this free system
again no really Dand I've come to
bargain and you've been in the system as
long as I have you hear many promises
many
reassurances any Brave plan this fascist
video game world has got to end yes
there they are with a
guardian
Yuri who is your user program alen one
alen you may pass my friend you shall
not
pass the Tower Guardian is helping him
man's on a swivel bring in the logic
probe open logic
pro there's also some Metropolis in this
movie it's so unique but it is also like
classical in a way it's fascinating
that's my word of the movie
fascinating beam him up
Scotty
oh oh oh oh success it appears so it's
begun it has beun you're creating the
information on your dis that will erase
the mCP and change change the system
oh we will not be able to communicate
again unless you succeed damn hopefully
that disc hasn't been corrupted with the
thinking probe this is the key to a new
order yes where's the program what
program take
him oh put him in the Iron Maiden this
solar sailor simulation will take us
across the game sea out of this domain
back into the Central Computer cross the
game
sea look
out
[Music]
ug let's
go oh oh
[Laughter]
no yeah I'm not wasting my time I'll
just jump my man is a pragmatic program
if nothing
else
[Music]
wowe
wow cross that
[Music]
sea excellent sense of scale getting
shades of the first opening shot of A
New Hope oh yeah definitely I wonder how
you take in a poket
calculator we did take care of that user
you sent us put him in a TI 83 almost
reached your decision gab and I can't
spare you any more time and of
line and of line yeah greetings program
you're alive barely I'm a
Survivor oh oh disguise gone yeah do you
get to equip that later how's your
inventory work where's Ram a he didn't
make it ra to rip I can't get the
Matthew MCC look out of
my you see it too right sure okay good I
knew it wasn't just me we'll get a
montage of him just in a light cycle
monologuing
pensively this is Flynn the one who
busted me out Laura well then I owe him
some thanks oh I out of know my way
around the light cycle routine I wrote
the program for it you wrote the program
it's time I'd level with you I'm what
you guys call a user are you God you
just keep doing what it looks like
you're supposed to be doing no matter
how crazy it seem unless the way it is
programed I hate to disappoint CH pal
but most of the time that's the way it
is for users too oh we are the programs
oh nice looking ship you got
here nice looking pilot too yeah they
going to have to fight out the love
triangle here in the program too prepare
him for Inquisition I need a little bit
of relaxation but first res up the
carrier for Pursuit one other thing
don't think anymore I do the thinking
around here sir yes sir I don't give you
enough information to think nobody
expects the digital
Inquisition this isn't going to be easy
if those grid bugs get us we've had it
oh
my
CSH little bouncy guys had enough what
do you want Oh old enough to remember
the mCP when it was just a chess program
he started small and he'll end small
yeah funny Dumont maybe I should keep
you around just to make me laugh how
dare you treat the architect like that
yeah what's happening power search from
the mCP we have to get off this beam I
can't there isn't another Junction for 7
or eight
NS there's another beam
[Music]
oh got to be something you you can do
man absorb the energy creating a
junction
who wowee
cool if I had seen this as a kid I I
would have thought this was so freaking
cool I still think it's so freaking cool
but yeah my mind would have just been
blown to bits I would have been
pretending to be inside the machine all
the time yeah did we make it
yeah yeah seeing this in theater again
mind just blown but it's still fun to
watch now oh yeah it still feels like
you're you're experiencing something
unprecedented and it is like a piece of
art because of that like you could just
tell how much like how many multiple
departments worth of craftsmanship and
design and like painstaking cell
manipulation like oh my God is he deing
no but I couldn't tell you why not you
can't hear the da Punk that's why
exactly the one thing I know about Tron
legacy is is dresed yes how did you do
that Elementary physics a beam of energy
can always be diverted are we there yet
mommy yes
daddy glad you finished your homework
that's why they fired him you got too
smart you can't be controlled you won't
fall in line like a good
program
[Music]
yeah interesting we haven't seen clue
this entire time yeah I wonder if he
would come back well I mean he's the
user and I mean the user and the program
are completely separate yeah I I think
at least yeah maybe we'll have some kind
of end Showdown or
something or they'll leverage him with
clue oh whoa that's
bad
I'm curious who did the composing for
this film tron's dead he fell on his
head he came here to help us he's a
filthy land monkey so we have erased
that program
yeah take that program to the holding
pit oh boy control your anger yeah like
when he gets super he gets extra that
temper is going to be the downfall of
you I just Embark oh this ship and
everything that remains on board will
automatically
Dres dude them are fighting words well
yes thank you for
[Music]
clarifying how many more of these ships
do you have I feel like this would be a
resource worth
salvaging oh yeah you knew they couldn't
take down the man so easily he's like
Flynn he's a Survivor rout us to the mCP
I want to get rid of this dead way and
catch a transport beam to the game
domain certainly something's
happening that's so cool love some of
these the way they've staged a lot of
these shots yeah the craftsmanship I
can't imagine how many hours upon hours
it took for them to do yeah well and
even the stuff that's all computer
digital is like still kind of framed
with camera motions that look cinem so
it Blends well into the movie
yeah it's like it's easy to overlook
that cinematography is a part of this
type of Animation even at this point in
time oh yeah remember you are
wireframing to wireframe you shall
return leave me alone we failed we're
only going to fail if we give up now
come on look look wall all hope is not
lost yeah let's combine our power why
did you bring me back I need your help
come
on I drank all that energy water
earlier that's so cool oh he's okay so
that's yeah when he spins he is a solid
color
form
ah
whoa whoa it's the mCP it's the heart of
the whole
[Music]
system yeah oh no no oh I love the skull
embellishments another Warrior is on the
Meson slave it doesn't matter prepare to
terminate
ouch not
today all programs have a desire to be
useful no you're very persistent TR I'm
also better than you
yeah you going to take that flip your
antlers up
[Music]
[Applause]
man whoa not
bad all my functions are now
yours take them oh man what an
upgrade this would be like if somebody
made an open world video game out of
this be so
[Music]
cool oh is he just growing in sizes is
he giant man he is
growing wow
cool what good will that
do I'm going to jump it's an arc reactor
yes this is how Tony Stark defeated him
years later God the
colors wow oh my
God
whoa what is so
cool a here we go I shall become more
powerful than you can possibly imagine
become the main Central program
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
Victory whoa back to
[Music]
Stone
oh
there goes your box of
[Music]
scraps oh beautiful we now now a land of
Freedom yeah now it'll become a screen
[Music]
saver so cool feels like sci-fi Terry
Gilliam I need to watch a lot more of
his movies I really have not seen barely
any oh go watch Brazil
boy it's nice isn't she just kissing
Jeff Bridges you know he charged her up
but I guess so he threw himself into the
beam and distracted the mCP just long
enough for you to get the disc in he
saved us he really did it he was able to
save us in a cave with a box of
scraps you are now exiting the Matrix
reverse movie
sign this is kind of like a digitized
kaleidoscope version of the History
Science Theater
countdown
hey my man I just had the strangest
dream
yes space hey he got his credit space
paranoids Priority
[Music]
One
oh it's it again it's not going to be
able to talk back is how's he going to
function without the mCP
[Music]
yes what is this blasphemy you're free
man oh Jesus
Christ my
God
over look at those lapels see I would
have just lived at the
arcade a pretty nice time lapse I like
it I love this music so much yeah
yeah oh okay wow who is Steven lisberger
I don't
know and Bonnie mcbird wait for the
after credit scene yes of course the
sequel tag I want to see who did the uh
music I'm curious yeah absolutely it 82
so and I have to imagine that you know
the the score elements and the you know
sound design overall had to be
interacting a lot oh
yeah I almost thought that said Jeff
Goldblum yeah Jeff Goldblum edited this
movie Yes ah uh I say we edit ah ah like
ah ah this uh
golly ah Wendy Carlos huh good name but
I've never heard of her a woman composer
too you don't see you don't see Slash
here very
often wow and a lot of notable
orchestras and Phil harmonics thrilled
to be partnering with a brand I've been
using for nearly 2 years now and that's
Harry's Razors I'm generally more drawn
to anything that goes against the norm
and Harry's does just that in The
Grooming World they saw the high prices
in the industry and decided to blaze
their own trail with quality and
affordability I keep a beer but whenever
you see these cheeks in the neck clean
and that's the work of Harry's right
there keeps my wife happy and Harry's
makes it effortless they're Precision
Blades that cut smoothly with less drag
making every shave satisfying and yes
it's versatile
for other areas too you know what I mean
so as a Harry's dvo can vouch for their
value you can experience unparalleled
comfort and quality in your grooming
routine where exceptional craftsmanship
meets affordability making a smart
choice for a top- notot shave without
breaking the bank their kits and value
packs for shaving are unbeatable but
Harry's is not just about shaving again
they offer top quality thoughtfully
designed grooming products including
shampoo conditioner and amazing body
wash without the premium price quality
affordability that's a thesis of this
now these I actually pulled right from
my own bathroom I regularly use their
five blade razor with a nice weighted
handle and their foaming shave gel man
this that oh it is a game changer I just
like the feel of it now I have to commit
to keeping this in my hand the whole
time cuz I'm not going to go to the
bathroom in the middle of shooting this
the handles they feel perfectly balanced
and the razor Sleek design is a classy
addition to my bathroom and the quality
of the shave unparalleled got to
reiterate key part of my weekly grooming
ritual cuz their entire range of
products fits seamlessly into my routine
definitely no re-shoot here their German
engineer blades are durable and refill
plans are economical rarely use the word
economical but I'm using it now plus
their commitment to high customer
satisfaction and no risk trial makes
Harry's a no-brainer this Joe really
does feel good let me say once more
choosing Harry's means quality and
affordability by grabbing your $13 trial
set for just $3 at harry's.com rejects
you're not only getting a great deal but
you're also supporting this Channel
That's harry's.com rejects for your $3
trial set stay sharp and embrace the
extraordinary with Harry's till next
time reject Nation till next time big
thanks to express vpan for sponsoring in
this video a real game changer I've been
using for years that's right years so
whenever they want to work with us it's
an instant yes you've likely heard about
Express vpan for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum showing
down my internet and contacting me due
to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
Express vpm my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this
channel knows you can use expressvpn to
watch movies and shows on Netflix that
are not available in your country this
means accessing a vast rate of content
of over a 100 countries like a global
Cinema your fingertips it's super easy
open expressvpn switch locations refresh
the browser and there you have it
whether it's kramas on South Korea
Netflix Hulu BBC I player YouTube or
more expressvpn has you covered and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile out too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com reex so head to
expressvpn.com reex to learn more thank
you again I you know what I really
enjoyed it I mean it's definitely a bit
dated but I mean we I I think are you
talking about it's not dated at all the
effects are groundbreaking is to to
Journey um I mean it's a little dated
but you know what I don't care because I
can only imagine like being we mentioned
a couple times during the reaction like
if we were in the theater in 1982
watching this or even just seeing it now
in the theater too but like mind
absolutely tripped and blown like at the
time of seeing this uh you know with the
the uh the sound designs and just all
the uh all the sequences uh in the
gaming digital world if you will it's
just completely groundbreaking and so
cool and I did read a really cool
interesting fact just one thing I did
read about this film was uh it said
something like they didn't uh in the
Academy Awards that year they didn't
include this film for best visual
effects because they said it would be
considered cheating um well come on I
mean I get how I guess it's like it's
going to be like well here's why bother
nominating anybody else but at the same
time I'm like this is yeah suris yeah no
but I just I thought it was very
interesting World building and just
again just very ground breaking effects
I also I love Jeff Bridges in this movie
he brought such an infectious energy
that I really appreciate it I haven't
seen a ton of Jeff Bridges movies being
very transparent with you guys I've seen
a couple obviously everyone knows I've
seen Iron Man um but yes um but I have
not seen too many of his films but I
love the energy he brought to this film
I really uh you know cared about his
character I was very invested in him and
just like his journey that he went
through in the game and uh just like
making sure I wanted to get him out of
out of the game in a very safe manner as
well yeah excuse me um and also too like
I felt bad for his character too like
having you know been ridiculed and fired
from his job and everything that
happened so uh but again I just I love
the energy he brought to this he was so
just uh enatic and energetic and I just
appreciated his performance but what do
you think of the Phil yeah I agree I
mean this was I I've heard you know this
movie has its Legacy over time and I've
have heard it said before that like it's
it's one of those Classics that not
everybody agrees is like great
necessarily and I've often heard people
be like it's kind of boring or like ah
you know for the time it's it's cool but
like watching it now but I was actually
really into this and I was really kind
of taken with the obviously the digital
art on display but moreover just the way
it it added it it's funny there's like
an ironic tangibility that this movie
had for my experience of it because be
you know the way the effects are
orchestrated yes certain scenes are just
all computer simulated but so much of
this is also combining obviously
liveaction photography with all those
bits and pieces and and you can tell
just with the Jitters on the edges
around characters and stuff like that
that so many of these frames
must have had to have been cut out and
colored onto and you know to get all the
different glowing patterns and stuff
like there's just so much craft and
Artistry that would have had to have
taken place on something like this and
so yeah it's like even though this is a
groundbreaking you know Tech demo in a
lot of ways uh it also felt sort of
classic to me and it was reminding me of
a lot of other movies too in a good way
in a way that you know uh it didn't feel
like it was only deriving from those you
know it's like people recently have been
dogging on like Rebel Moon cuz Rebel
Moon feels like it's a mast of a bunch
of other movies parts and it doesn't
really have as much of its own
personality whereas here I mean I
definitely thought about Star Wars I
thought about Metropolis I thought about
uh even like Fantastic Voyage but if you
were in a computer The Matrix like
there's so much stuff a little bit
before and definitely a lot after that
you know borrows from it and homages
this but yeah I thought the the world of
the game and the Machine like it's one
that you want to hop further into and
explore just the details and the rules
and the lore of and I like that yeah you
have this you know almost Gladiator like
system it almost feels like you're in
some kind of ancient Rome where you have
this emperor in the the main you know
program who is and and again you know we
we live in the time of AI so you've got
this program that has you know amassed
and learned and generated its own will
and is now sort of running a muck on
things and you don't get the sense that
there are huge real world Stakes right
away but they're threatening like oh I'm
going to hack into the Pentagon next you
know and the Kremlin yeah the Kremlin
and all that stuff and so like those
elements I think have aged up and have
gotten more relevant and and yeah and it
has that Charming 80s hook of like oh
it's it's you know this guy with a video
game arcade who like wrote this game and
that stuff reminded me of free guy too
or where you know that movie involves
you know characters who live inside the
game but also the designer and the
company who made the game and the
politics of all that and you know both
stories are kind of working together in
the stakes and so uh yeah but but as it
pertains to just this uh I really
enjoyed the
performances uh and I enjoyed yeah just
the way that this really felt like I was
watching something classic and something
again that almost felt like when you're
in TR uh in the machine if when you're
in the program and you're watching
actors especially in closeup like it
really did feel like watching some kind
of old silent movie or something just
the way that yeah just the way the image
quality looks the grain of the film that
they used I wonder if they shot some of
those scenes in like black and white and
colorized them on like black and white
stock or something um but yeah the sound
designs when they were inside the
program in the game it was so
fascinating and I love too A lot of the
visuals when we were inside like
especially at the end with the whole
spinning thing and like uh it felt like
very religious like a temple that they
were in that was really fascinating was
the the word that came to mind very of
made me think of Dune in that yes I was
thinking I was thinking of Dune very
much I know Dune came out at least the
the the was it the David um what's the
David Lynch one David Lynch one came out
two years after the corner but yeah yeah
I was still I was thinking of dude for
sure and that's the funny thing about
this experience to me as well is that
this movie again obviously haven't seen
Tron legacy either excited to check that
out after this but Tron Legacy uh like
the the trailer for that feels like that
trailer it's a great trailer and and and
the kind of movie that that trailer
looks like I guess is sort of what I had
expected from a movie like this and I
expected that movie to be in the
tradition of whereas I can kind of
almost feel
like I get the sense it's just a guess
but you know like the Tron legacy will
probably feel more like a big action
Blockbuster and this C has that quity
too but I don't know like there's
something about the way that movie
presented itself where I'm like okay so
this is going to be a lot of like jousts
and light cycle fights and and you know
it's it's almost going to feel like some
kind of bigger budget yeah but something
that's also like in a dystopian way sort
of more focused on these particular
games or something whereas this like
sprawled out and it's like yeah you have
a light cycle race or or two you have
one in game context and then one in real
Stakes context
and then you know the rest of it you're
moving through all these different areas
of the world it's it kind of Moves Like
A sidescroller in a way because you're
constantly going to new places and
seeing new facets of the machine even
though those were completely digital and
it felt like we were watching a game
like I still had that claustrophobic
feel when we were inside that and and
the sound design and the way the
cinematography Moves In Those scenes
like just did such a good job of making
me like again just feel that intense
claustrophobia and like scared for our
are uh feeling the stakes for our
characters yeah absolutely and like I
like that again like that lent that lent
the feeling of being in some kind of
ancient empire or or like a you know
Star Wars type you know futuristic space
Empire and obviously the big ship is
supposed to you know make you think of
Star Wars um going after the little ship
but yeah and having those like little
flourishes that feel like cult or
religion and and yeah this just had so
many more elements and details and and a
totally different way of moving and
breathing than I was expecting and it
was reminding me of of things I hadn't
expected in terms of just the broad
scope of Cinema and so yeah this felt
like watching some kind of big budget
but also sort of avant piece of art you
know I felt like I was and I haven't
seen all of THX 11138 or whatever it
felt like you were dipping into one of
those things where it's like you can
feel the hands that made this it's not
so polished that it doesn't feel like
people made this and uh and yeah I don't
know it it's this was a lot more
fascinating than I expected it to be in
so many ways and and yeah like I I feel
like again that that Association I grew
up with was like oh people think this is
kind of boring but like I don't know I
was really really enthralled by this
overall and uh I mean you know like the
outside characterizations in the real
world could be he was Billy the Kid yes
all right but we got to check oh he was
also in Air Force One cool we got to
check about me though John so you only
check about about you yeah that's right
that's right what about me about who do
we need to who do we need to ver Barnard
Hughes I want to see if he's in Sister
Act Two father Maurice that's the
important yeah we got to get oh man
Sister Act 2 father Maurice father
Maurice there you go we both got one we
both got one high five Andrew that's
what this machine fun fact too Sister
Act 2 was directed by Bill Duke oo yes
thank you so much Bill Duke and Predator
we loved you we he directed that I was
for a second I was like wait you mean
the guy from Predator yeah no uh he he
played Mac in Predator yeah yeah yeah he
didn't direct Predator no no no John M
but he directed Sister Act to he
directed Sister Act to you can go check
and see if I'm wrong John's like I trust
you I do there's anybody I trust with
trivia oh my God by the way uh we forgot
to mention at the beginning of this
review if you have not already if you
are listening on Spotify or apple if you
don't mind giving us a rating we'd so
much appreciate Tron wood myself uh what
was my name an and clue I would
appreciate it uh that was kind of I
thought we were going to go back to that
too with the whole clue character but I
I okay he got okay okay I I don't know I
didn't I guess I I didn't pick up on all
the rules but I guess you're right
that's why I have you here for you're
the smarter one clearly of the pair here
um if I ever were to transport into a
universe like Tron I would need the
actual Tron character here uh to survive
so uh but let us know when took me by
surprise too sorry yeah just the Tron is
this like is this savior esque po like
very simplified not for the same purpose
almost polres type where it's like it's
not even Jeff Bridges does save the day
but but he he opens up the opportunity
for Tron to do it which is neat which is
like oh like even calling it Tron naming
it after the Savior yeah but who's not
like the main main main character is is
just a neat FLIR there's so many neat
FLIR yeah I mean other than the ground
bre breaking uh visual effects and all
that and Jeff Bridges just being I
thought the name of the game was drawn
but I that's that shows some and space
paranoids baby and da Punk is uh the
soundtrack of the second one that's how
much I knew about this one but I I
rather enjoyed it again the
groundbreaking effects especially at the
time really cool I love Jeff Bridges
this is is now we going to watch Juan
lower man right yes but let us know in
the comments section what did you think
does it still hold up for you are you
nostalgic about it after all this time
do you want Tron and include doing uh
Tron legacy we'd love to hear you
thought we need some tap punk in our
lives let us know in the comment section
we'd love to hear for you do all the
YouTube things subscribe hit the Bell
icon all notifications hit that like
button we would appreciate it and we
shall see you on the next one
peace